okay let's take some phone calls at 6 1
7 8 3 0 47 50 and see what's on people's
minds why don't we start today with our
caller from the two-five to area code
who's calling today from 2 5 - hey David
this is Kiana hey how you doing you said
your name is Keenan
nokey on T on D on ok good yeah yeah
Shion I called like 2 times before but
this is awesome
Oh so my question for you is well so I
mean this was a while ago but Donna
Karan stuff on nationalists and I know
you say you didn't agree with
nationalism I don't want to strawman you
but I know you said that there was not
you call yourself a patriot not a
nationalist and my question to you is
like I know there's different forms of
nationalism and I think that this is one
of those things that I do not want the
right to have a monopoly on sure because
I know this liberal nationalism and
civic nationalism and that's notice it
has a very complicated history
so will you reconsider like the this the
like we do reconsidered like zip it
nationalism or liberal nationalism
listen I don't remember saying I'm a
patriot not a nationalist I think I
remember saying there's a difference
between patriotism and nationalism I'd
have to go back and listen to the clip
here's my thing here's your you're
pointing out very astutely the problem
with a lot of these political labels so
for me the problem is not the idea of
nationalism per se in some kind of you
know amorphous or hypothetical sense
it's that very often what the American
right which as you say has has done a
pretty good job of monopolizing the term
nationalism and patriotism what they
mean by that is a very particular we're
better than other countries our people
are better we know everything we have
the best system the idea that we should
look to Europe for what to do on health
care or to whatever they're against that
and that
have a problem with now if nationalism
were rebranded as hey you know what we
are going to design the best cities that
reduce structural segregation along
racial and economic lines and we are
going to take pride in the fact that we
have modernized our public transit
systems such that it's the envy of the
world like those are things that for me
are more logical to be sort of
nationalistic about so I agree with you
I would love to sort of take back
control of the concept of nationalism
but the term itself has been pretty
tainted at this point I mean a
particular reactionary thing yeah I look
at you and like cuz I know like I've
been thinking over there over the past
few months about certain things like I
don't know like client says I know that
there generally has allergy towards like
nationalism there are certain things
that do this whole thing I forgot a few
other terms up the other things but I
know there is a few things that list has
a allergy toys and look everyone
understand because of the history but
like like you know I'm just got to think
more carefully about these things in the
night world I mean yes you know math
numbers if you you know the there was
two world wars they devastated Europe
because of expansionist nationalism and
actually anti-semitic we brains of
national yes now we're getting into
something a little bit different Tiana I
appreciate the call I'm gonna let you go
it's a very very good topic and I'm glad
that you are thinking about these issues
so deeply that's a very very good thing